martin heidegger is undoubtedly
the most important thinker of the occident
he himself even described his
philosophy as fundamental ontology therefore
wanted to show the deepest foundations of the world to understand understanding of today's
interested
beyond the individual sciences the
underlying meaning of life in general his
central question is therefore what is it
meaning of being
but if we ask about the meaning of ropes
and thus about the meaning of life
we must first
of all investigate heidecker as he is th
one who asks this strange question about the meani
g well and the questioner is th
human being himself we are becau
e we  as the only creatures in the world
to ask the question of meaning at all it does
n't make an animal humans are constantly
looking for orientation and that's why
saint describes life as a great
challenge it doesn't live by
itself but requires many
decisions and we can also
miss our senses  meaning of our life
saint puts forward the provocative
thesis that even most of us live in
an actual mode of
existence and miss our actual meaning
so you only do what you do you go
to school you earn money you go on
vacation instead of realizing what our
own life means and how we
can realize ourselves yes how we
can leave the beaten path
but how do i know what suits me
and what doesn't how do i find my
destiny is not easy the book
holy 60 minutes also explains
its existence analysis using its most important quotes
in an understandable way
and takes the reader on an
adventurous journey into the deepest
structures of our existence and there will
hardly be any of us or
you who does not read these structures, the
character of existence or the fear
of nothing,
which shows us the sacred  own
experiences projected and
can project what use u  ns
heidecker discovery today i actually think
that we are very good at bringing saints
into consideration for our personal life as well